my name is Brian Holt I have a PhD and
artificial intelligence from MIT and I'm
a post fellow at Cambridge and today
we're gonna talk about how AI works so
AI you take a lot of data a whole lot of
data a metric ton of data for measuring
and you send it into the the RDA is its
multiple ai's here and the AI is take
all of your data and they process it and
they massage it and they put it into the
mystical fairies in gremlins and you get
magic out of it this is this is the
fundamental concepts of how AI works
just getting I'm not a data scientist
I'm a college dropout I've never been to
college so you all thought I was serious
[Laughter]
no one was laughing I was like oh god
they think this is real
okay so Who am I really
I'm I am the college dropout that is
true and I left Scotland I was actually
just there last week for Scotland Jess
and that's my lovely wife and I love to
show pictures of her on stage because
she hates it her name's Nikki and she's
not here so I can do it
I work for this tiny startup you see at
the top there you might have heard of it
it's a it's perhaps Microsoft it's
pretty indie it's pretty underground
stuff so I wouldn't even you probably
wouldn't haven't heard of it so it's
good okay
I've worked a couple of these other
smaller startups as well
reddit Netflix linked it in so so in
other words I have absolutely kind of no
like moral authority to talk about AI I
didn't take statistics in college I've
never really written much AI and so when
I was given this talk to
present to you I was like what am I
gonna tell these people especially since
I saw like people in here from like
tensorflow is like oh god I gotta talk
to these people like some serious
imposter syndrome going on I know it's
okay it's okay so I wanted to define
some terms for you and kind of like help
us kind of get on the same page I want
to help you identify what AI can do for
you how to interact with AI and kind of
take some of like the mysticism away
from AI so it doesn't feel so much like
magic anymore so it feels like another
tool in your toolbox that you can use to
apply to solve problems right another
pattern in your programming brain
pattern matching that you can say oh
cool this is something that could use
some sort of AI or machine learning
algorithm technique
my problem with AI in general in terms
of like how companies are positioning AI
is we kind of have this like dichotomy
of ideas of what AI is we first had on
one side we have Tron and Blade Runner
and 2001 a space ask you like you
haven't seen a lot of head shaking yeah
like we had this ideas like this
sentient being that I'm going to feed
data into and it's going to process it
in some some way that I can't anticipate
much like I'd have a conversation with
you and I can't anticipate what you're
going to have right what you're going to
say back to me rather it's not the case
with AI but these companies are
positioning the marketing's who kind of
a lean into that idea that they think
like that you think that that's what
you're getting out of it it's not
actually the case so let's talk about
like what is AI then AI is anything that
makes your app seem intelligent I'm time
at and I'm actually serious that's
actually what it means right so at the
most base level AI is often just a
series of if statements if we're being
honest with each other
right but like rolling that back a
little bit how many look can you
remember back to like a time when you've
been using some sort of application and
you've been surprised at the
intelligence of it right
you've been surprised it like I've fed
something into this and it's giving back
me back something that like I
anticipated or I found insightful and it
didn't really feel like interacting with
the machine right I fell liked
interacting with some sort of sentience
right so that's kind of what AI is is
it's those kind of moments that it's
that you're interacting with that you're
kind of getting these moments out of it
so I want to talk about some of the this
gift just worries me like she's happy
then she smelled something and then she
realized it was her so for me the kind
of mom I'm gonna I can't watch this okay
for me like one of the times that I had
one of these moments is what the first
time I started interacting with like one
of those AI assistants kind of like
Alexa or Siri or okay Google I usually
wait to see if someone's phone goes off
and I say that it's happened before
hey Siri
so someone out here is like no turned it
down so that was for me when I first got
like my virtual assistant that was kind
of the first moments like when I asked
it like I don't know some tests like
tell me the stock price of this what's
the weather and it gave me back what I
was actually looking for and like that
for me it felt like it was like a mini
Turing test that had passed right like I
didn't realize I was interacting with a
machine I realized that I felt like I
was interacting with a person or
something like that right so unlike
these very minute miniature interactions
like it kind of passes the Turing test
the Turing test is like when you're
interacting with the Machine and you
don't actually realize that you're
interacting with the Machine right
that's that's what the Turing test is so
yeah like those moments kind of like
help you like interface with an
interface without realizing that you're
actually interfacing with it right so
it's an interface list interface it's
intuitive it's something that you
understand
not ever having seen it before like
whenever you pick up a new program or a
new machine or something like that
there's like a learning curve with it
right you have to you have to learn to
interact with the interface and you have
to conform to the interface and AI is
coming the other way it's conforming to
your interface it's understanding what
your intentions without you
understanding the interface thereof so
that's kind of what AI is then like
whenever you hear people talking about
AI this is kind of how you should frame
it
oh no yeah you're not watching that
again so AI and ML often come together
right like they're kind of like a
package deal but there they are they do
mean separate things but often you are
using ml machine learning to excuse me
you're after using ml to achieve some
sort of artificial intelligence right so
ml is the idea that you're going to
teach a machine to generalize the task
for you now this is a very this is
actually more of a subset of what ml is
there's actually several things that ml
can do we're gonna there's supervised
learning there's unsupervised learning
there's rien first reinforced learning
and I was just told that there's
actually semi-supervised learning I
don't know what that means so I'm not
gonna talk about it so I'm gonna talk
about a little bit more about supervised
learning because that's what I've
actually dealt with so at the most basic
layer what is supervised learning well
you have some set of data you go through
and you label a bunch of that data is
like this is spam or not spam or
something like that and based on doing
that repeatedly and giving a bunch of
this kind of data you hand it to some
sort of algorithm it kind of processes
that makes a bunch of associations kind
of that you don't understand like hidden
associations as they're often called and
it kind of uses that to learn further
and further so that you can start giving
it things that you don't actually know
what it is but it can start classifying
for you so I want to give you an example
of something like this so pretend that
you work in the bank does anyone in here
work at some sort of financial
institution I'm so sorry you can just
see like the sadness in their face I'm
just kidding
I used to do payments for Netflix so I
understand things like PCL it did give
me status at Mis that's why I say
okay so so you work at a bank I imagine
many of you have on your like phone app
so you can take a picture of a check and
it deposits a check for you right it's a
pretty common thing imagine that your
boss came to you is like okay we have
these checks and we want to be able to
orient these checks in the correct way
right makes sense in order to process
the check you probably need to have it
oriented the correct way so I need you
today to go build that kind of thing and
bring it back to you this is the only
check that you have to do it for I
imagine most of you are kind of thinking
I was like okay well I think maybe like
detect like the names or I can look for
the numbers on the top right or maybe
like that lock right that lock there on
the right since that's always going to
be there you could probably like look
for that in the pixels find if it's
oriented because of the curb or
something like that and you could figure
it out right most of us today could go
out and build something like this from
hand to do this I feel confident that I
could do I don't want to but I could
okay
so feeling pretty good you could build
this you go back to your boss you said I
did it
we can now orient all the checks okay so
maybe a month goes by boss comes back to
your desk and he's like well I have this
really adorable dock and this dog's name
is Fifi I've decided and I'm gonna put
Fifi on our checks so we're gonna have
the other check and now we're gonna have
Fifi checks so I need you to build
another check or another orienting kind
of process based on this so you
progressively stop whatever you're doing
maybe something more important than this
and you obliged your boss if you go out
and is you're gonna build how to orient
VP cheques correctly I think I would
probably lie you know maybe look for the
lock again that might be a good idea or
maybe look at the face the dog like
there's several things you can do here
this look for to make sure that you
orienting the checks that way you go
back you build it and like rising
walking to the door your boss says like
oh well I just actually had a photo
shoot with Fifi and now we have all
these checks all the Fifi checks and
Fifi also has a sibling that's on one of
the checks
so I need you to build all of these
these checks right and at this point
you're starting to get like oh crap why
did I take this job why don't I go work
it like the other bank or something like
that right so I think you can kind of
see where I'm going with this that this
this problem space is ever-expanding
because of your neurotic boss right but
nonetheless at this point we're still at
like within a reasonable problem space
that you could still build it for all of
these right because there's not that
many there's like five more of them
right okay so next week the box come
back and he's like I have this just like
moment I was like in the shower and I
want you to build it for any background
image all of the background images build
this so it works with any background
image and at this point at least if it
was me I'd look a little something like
this right actually reenacted and like
raising my arms like no so this this
problem is something that MLL would be
really really really good for and this
this was like a light bulb moment for me
is like it takes a problem that you know
how to solve right so if I give you any
input you could programmatically go
personally and solve that to that like a
finish for that particular problem right
so basically is like you have the input
and you know what the output for that is
going to be and you could you could
personally write that code for it
yourself right this is what ml is really
good at it's good at taking this idea of
like I could build this myself and then
generalizes it to everything right so
that you don't have to go write the code
for everything you can just rely on ml
to solve these kind of problems for you
so like I want to kind of like add that
into your toolbox of something that like
if your boss comes to you with a problem
of this sort that you could say a cool
this is something I could use ml for
this isn't really that magical at all
hopefully you're looking at this and say
I'm like okay like this is cool like
this is something that I can understand
so there's several flavors of this I'm
going to run over just some of them this
is something that I built using you can
see down at the bottom with my
stuff cognitive services again I'm not
an AI developer I haven't like I just
messed around this pi torch a little bit
and like not much more than that this
wonderful is this how I'm gonna work for
this divided by 10 very creative
repeat
so that's a little reading shut up run
okay so that's something that I built
and really actually in a very very short
amount of time and just threw up on cope
and cope and still up there you even put
like my API keys in there so you could
probably use those yourself don't this
is built with a tool called
Lewis Lewis III it's a language
understanding something that begins with
I service and it's really cool it allows
someone like me like I don't know
anything about natural language
processing I don't know how I would
never be able to know personally how to
build this but I just throw things at
the API and then I go into this
interface um which is what I'm showing
what the website looks like and I just
go and type a bunch of things like this
is what this might look like right so if
I if I'm having the calculator that
multiply intent then it might look like
multiplied by five times it by 5
multiplied by 5 all these various like
you know ways that we have if expressing
in English how to multiply something and
then it trains its own model behind the
scenes for you and then it allows you to
start doing these things so I found that
really cool and something that
personally very useful to me is
particularly cuz I'm cutting out a bunch
of work that I don't have to go build
this right you could go out and build
like a the craziest regular expression
ever to try and figure out if you
someone's trying to multiply or
something or or something like that but
who really wants to build regular
expressions no hands cool ok no no one's
that crazy how so crazy but maybe yeah
anyway so I hear this constantly from
people though is I don't like putting
things in my code that I don't
understand this is a very common like
sentiment that people come back to me
and say I don't understand what's going
on underneath the hood like I don't like
who knows what it's gonna come out of
that model all that kind of stuff right
so the example that I like to give to
people for this is how PDF generation
works right so imagine that I'll give
you a text file and this is something
I've literally had to do before I need I
give you some sort of text file and then
to generate some sort of PDF from it so
how many of you know how to generate
PDFs I'm so sorry
that that's not knowledge you want to
have right like it sits in your brain is
like I wish I didn't have to go down
that path again like this guy had like
the thousand foot letters like I know
right it's it now I think based on the
scrap you're gonna see this works
relatively similar to how AI works right
like it goes onto some PDF maker that
you bought from someone or someone open
sourced and then you never have to think
about it right so I did you all a favor
and I opened a PDF with the text
document and that's what it looks like
right how many of you have opened a PDF
of text before I think you are some
weird people I have I hadn't before this
and I notice that there's a bunch of
Apple symbols in there so I think
there's some sort of conspiracy about
this but I'm not I'm not really sure yet
it sounds oh maybe I'll feed it in by AI
in my AO will tell me what's what the
conspiracy is but hopefully you're kind
of getting my point about like you don't
actually really care how the PDF
generator works right you feed something
into it and you get the desired output
out of it you don't actually really to
know how it works in fact could you make
a PDF builder today if I like if I asked
you like I'm gonna give you six months
ago build me a PDF generator I probably
everyone in here because like shaking
there's like yeah I don't want to but if
you pay me enough money I'll do whatever
you want right it's kind of how I feel
so you could build this you just don't
want to now I'm on the same boat I was
like I can build this I wanted to but I
don't want to someone else built it for
me I just want to throw money at them
and just get the library from them so
this is kind of actually what what AI is
doing for us now I'm going to give you
the most simplified perhaps wrong
explanation of how convolutional neural
networks actually work so if anyone's
out there don't correct me because I
don't care
so the basic idea is you have a bunch of
data and it's gonna try and make
associations with the data around it
like if we're thinking about this in
terms of images which I think I find the
personal easiest way to think about it
you have like the blue one up there
being the answer right and you have
these kind of various associations of
like pixels are rounded associated with
other pixels around it right which in
turn are just really just wait right
it's some number between like zero and
one probably and whenever it's something
that's more associated that number goes
up whenever it's less associated it goes
down right and then anytime that you
want to adjust the algorithm you say
like well you told me it was this but is
actually this so it's actually going to
go and there's gonna be that blue circle
and it's gonna back propagate all of
those different weights and says like
actually this was what the real answer
wasn't it kind of just like ups those
ways so next time you come through it
it's going to go down that path instead
this is called back propagation right
and it's actually one of the fundamental
building blocks of how neural networks
work this at the end of the day just
ends up being a lot of like matrix math
which I remember doing I remember not
liking right to me oh and then this is
just one model like this is just one
incantation of it these actually get a
lot more complicated as you might
imagine there are many many many more
associations and then there are like
different levels of that you end up with
a ton of these models right and that's
kind of the idea of how this works now
you could build this right just like you
could build a PDF generator like I'm
confident that most of us could build
like a very basic level about if we went
delved into this and figured out like
all the math and kind of stuff because
like don't get me wrong like there there
there are levels of ml that are like far
more complicated that I'm
oversimplifying but at least at the top
layer the very base layer most of us
could build some sort of simple
incantation of this so you could build
this right you you could go through you
can learn all this you could figure it
all out and you could build this you
could even build this on top of
something yourself like something like
tensorflow or with pi torch or keris
which is on top of tensorflow but for
the most part often time
even you know higher level abstractions
on top of that which I'll talk about
here in just a second there you go
carry some height torch right so these
are two libraries that are awesome super
great you should definitely go mess
around with them they're in Python so I
don't know we're talking about a node
conference that's awkward so let's talk
about tensorflow jeaious which is super
cool because I feel like this opens the
door for node developers to start
messing around and not even just know
developers but browser developers to go
Matt start messing around with really
really cool stuff so we could start
getting these kind of really interesting
insights out of our data just and get to
use JavaScript throughout the entire
process I think it's just it's
democratizing ml to an entire new
demographic so the thanks tensorflow
team is super awesome this is one of
their demos I thought was fantastic they
fed up like in a bunch of midis into
tensorflow j/s and then they basically
let it machine learning generate music
and it's actually not bad right and I
like I found it to be super super
impressive this is something you should
definitely go check out it's on in their
documents and their examples so really
really cool stuff so just a plug here
for Microsoft cognitive services that
I'm pretty still pretty new at Microsoft
and so one of the first things I got to
do it was go in there with a bunch of
free as your credits and start messing
with Microsoft cognitive services now
all of the major providers of cloud
services as far as I know provides some
level of al ml so our AI ml and all that
kind of stuff so you could really mess
around with all these I'm just gonna
talk about cognitive services because I
get to play with it for free and you
can't do actually the free tiers for
this is actually pretty good so
cognitive services is taking this let
one layer on top of it
that we you could go train your data set
to recognize images and facial
recognition and stuff like that it's
something that you can definitely go do
yourself but why do yourself when
someone else could has done it for you
and that's a kind of the idea behind
cognitive services it's an API that you
just throw things that that's pre
trained with already like really good
datasets and it gives you back really
cool stuff so here's just like some of
the offerings like the computer
one's really cool the face-recognition
one my coworker brian clark built this
thing for his wedding that did facial
recognition based on a photo booth so
just you would take a picture it would
recognize your face and it would just
immediately email you all the pictures
pretty cool for a for a wedding right so
definitely something to check out again
the free tier is pretty compelling check
out any of them right like just start
messing around with a a IML add it to
your tool kit like kind of get that like
working into your brain and definitely
mess around with tensorflow J ass
because it's magical thank you
[Applause]